foreign
the coast of Florida has been host to
countless Tales of Behemoth great
hammerheads
sharks rivaling the great white in size
and weighing over 1 000 pounds
but is there any truth to these
fishermen's Tales
there's several species of hammerheads
that they have sort of New Kids on the
Block as far as evolution of sharks goes
gray Hammerheads are a bit different
from some of the other species now they
tend to be more solitary but they also
get much larger
maximum size of great Hammerheads has
long been disputed by science
but historical accounts and numerous
modern day sightings have put their true
potential into question
[Music]
there's a lot of local lore and
fishtails about how large these animals
can get
what is a big boy
no
or the internet
[Music]
record-sized hammerhead
it's really important that we're able to
find these really large great
Hammerheads because they're such
important apex predators
their expedition will see them exploring
part of the migration route of these
giant sharks
from the bridges of the Florida keys to
the shark-filled Waters of the Bahamas
when whatever it takes to come face to
face with the world's biggest hammerhead
it's coming to the surface fast oh
that's a big one monster whoa
[Music]
the team starts their expedition in the
Florida Keys a place famous for giant
hammerhead sightings
and an important location on the great
Hammerhead migration route South Florida
is a known popping ground for the great
Hammerhead so it stands to reason where
there's pups their mothers should be at
some point when they come to give birth
so this is a good spot to look for them
this is an area well known for large
great hammerhead sharks there's some big
Bridges with lots of water flow
underneath so our chances of catching
them here are pretty good
so we're trying to catch a really large
hammerhead shark so that we can put a
biologer on it
we've already tagged and got information
on small ones and medium-sized ones but
the big ones are sort of the Holy Grail
for us we don't know exactly what the
maximum size is of great Hammerheads
they're very very large very difficult
to catch and measure there have been
reports of some individuals that may
have been in excess of 20 feet now how
accurate those are we don't know
this great Hammerhead was actually
caught in Florida by a recreational
angler and it actually is the heaviest
and biggest great hammerhead shark
caught in the entire world and it was
donated for scientific research so they
actually learned quite a bit because
it's very rare to obtain a specimen of a
great Hammerhead of this size this is
very nearly as big as they get
it was 14.5 feet long and it was
1282 pounds could you imagine another
six feet added to this already enormous
shark and the amount of weight that
would be added with that must be
hundreds or even maybe a thousand pounds
so that would be an impressive animal to
see for sure
foreign
Hammerhead will have a very different
ecological role compared to let's say a
14 foot hammer head so our goal here is
to get the largest size range those
larger animals and try to understand
what role they may be having on the
ecosystem
to catch a large Hammerhead the team
will first need to figure out where a
giant could be hiding a needle in a
giant blue Haystack gray Hammerheads are
actually quite difficult to locate so
Yani and Aaron are going to go scuba
diving around some of the bridges where
Hammerheads have been seen and tennis
and I are going to go drops a beaded
remote underwater video cameras to sort
of provide some Intel on where they
might be
we're at the bridge now so I think we'll
go and take a look and see if there are
any sharks any Hammerheads obviously
specifically we'll also see what other
species of sharks are there I'm not sure
if this video he likes something nice is
pretty murky around here so fingers
crossed it's not too bad this is also a
spot they get really strong tidal
currents here so that basically means
we've got to keep this short tidal
colors can get really strong which makes
it unsafe especially if the visibility
is low which it often is under the
bridge so we'll just drive down take a
look around and then if the current is
is kind of ripping we can just head
right back up yeah
these bridges are great pleasure with
lots of current flow so that tends to be
a place where you get aggregating fish
and that includes prey items of
hammerheads like Tarpon and spotted
eagle Rays so as with all predators
hammer heads are going to go to
locations where they have a good chance
of finding prey and that makes Ridge
areas likely an attractive location for
them
if you don't want to be diving in very
strong colors when you have these
structures and objects that you could
head under the bridge
Hammerheads start off at just a few feet
long and then they can grow to really
large sizes and that's why it's really
important that we're able to find these
really large individuals because it
gives us this better picture as to how
they use energy and how their speed
changes and their behavior changes
throughout their lifetime
[Laughter]
Seasons we study gray Hammerheads is
because they are under serious threat
many sharks uh fish for their fins which
are used in shark fin soup but the
absolute Pinnacle is the fin from a
great Hammerhead it can fit a thousand
dollars a kilo so that has made these
gray Hammerheads a big Target and we
really need to get that under control so
these magnificent Predators remain in
our oceans
yeah I need Aaron out of the bridge
right now checking stuff out with their
eyes but we're going to upset some of
these cameras so what's the plan we have
five of these frames and we're gonna set
them kind of along a nice straight path
here using our randomly generated
locations we'll drop her down after
about an hour we'll come back pick her
up reset and continue doing that for the
day and then hopefully tonight when we
look at the video we'll see that we
actually came across a hammerhead oh
perfect that sounds great let's do it or
a baited remote underwater video station
is a really great tool for us all right
let's do it okay
we'll be able to put down a couple above
units and see yes this is indeed a hot
spot for Hammerheads
help us determine where we want to fish
for the large hammerhead
all right let's get the next one
well this is a pretty Sharky area so
fingers crossed we got some good stuff
yeah sounds good
all right
down here
[Applause]
we got in the current was quite strong
the visibility was awful honestly so
there's no sense wasting time on
something that's not going to be
valuable for us so we called the dive
pretty early this is a well-known Sharky
spot they see big Hammerheads there to
be honest a huge Hammerhead could have
gone past us and we'd have no idea so
oh did you see that Ray just fly out of
the water we did the dive and the
visibility was terrible it was almost
zero visibility so doing underwater
surveys is fairly pointless however
while we were there we did see jumping
Eagle Rays so we know that prey are
there which means again the chance of a
hammerhead there should be pretty good
so it's still worth our time to go and
fish there and see if we can catch a
really big shark
after being left for a couple of hours
Damian and Candice had out to retrieve
the bruffs
all right let's bring it back up let's
do it
okay
now we've done the boring bit by setting
these brubs but now we get to go back to
pick them up all right here it is yep
sweet
camera
yep still going
oh
still running uh yep sweet
pull it up all right here it is
which number is this this is the last
one oh sweet okay is it recording yep
sweet all right set it down
all right let's go home let's do it okay
Hammerhead hammerhead
I mean and Candace won't know if they're
successful until reviewing several hours
of underwater footage
the Bro footage caught several shark
species including tiger sharks and a
nurse shark
it's really cool reviewing the footage
because we got sharks
but not only that we got the one we're
looking for
[Music]
it looks like it's a juvenile gray
Hammerhead and where there's pups
there's big female coming here to give
birth
for sharks and definitely for great
Hammerheads the females are the larger
of the two Sexes much larger the reason
probably is because they just ate their
young and so they have to put on a lot
of weight have a lot of energy reserves
to carry those Offspring what's really
cool about seeing a juvenile is it might
not be that the big sharks are right
where the brother was set but it's good
evidence they're just in the general
area
now that we have a good idea of some
spots to fish we're going to get our
gear and head out
make sure you put this
this is a two-person I think
we're going to start off by trying to
fish under the bridges so we're going to
be on a boat with Val and Jack we have a
team very experienced with fishing for
sharks including large sharks so if we
catch one we'll be able to tag it we
just have to be able to find those
sharks yeah I think we're gonna get one
by lunch
we really only have two days of fishing
yeah done it before
there's really not a lot of data out
there that looks at the speed and
acceleration of great Hammerheads this
is something that's quite new and so
each data set that we get really
furthers our understanding about the
fine scale movements of this animal
there's a tag ready for deployment yeah
I can actually show you
we have this really cool piece of
technology that actually attaches to the
hammerhead's dorsal fin and allows them
to collect the data for us
as the shark swims along gets speed
acceleration magnetism depth and
temperature good and the video logger we
can see what the shark is seeing of
course this type of tag captures so much
data it can't transmit remotely so we
have to go physically go back and
retrieve it here in Florida
team's goal is bio logger on a
record-sized hammerhead shark
but with bad weather approaching they
only have a 48-hour window okey dokey
ready to fish I think we can start
getting the drum lines in the water
with two potential fishing grounds
identified the team decides to start at
the Bahia Honda bridge where Janus and
Aaron spotted potential prey
drumlining is a good system when you
really want to sort of minimize the
amount of time that an animal is on the
line it's simply a weight attached to a
float going to the surface and a hook
leading off it with a lot of leaders so
that if a shark does take the hook and
gets hooked up it can actually swim in
large circles it's never prevented from
swimming that's really important for the
safety of the animal ready
we don't want a single animal staying on
that line for too long because that can
be stressful and unfortunately we have
this technology called a hook timer it
actually shows us how long that animal
has been hooked so when the shark comes
you can pull on it but it's not going to
pop unless it's really forceful and it's
a magnet
all right we're in there you ready
mark
weights in
Team sets out eight drum lines and then
checks each one every 30 minutes wait
for it wait for it
clear so after this and we'll go and
check the other ones okay because
they've been out for over 30 minutes
some of them
when we're checking these drum lines
it's mentally and physically taxing
creeping up on it
we come up to the buoy grab the buoy
pull in the line check if there's bait
bait on
but
not even a nibble and do it all again
next one
it looks good grab the buoy pull in the
line check if there's bait do it all
again what do we got here nothing
nothing's on here and to do that with no
success for what you're going for it
takes a lot of mental and physical
strength
just non-stop the entire day just
checking these drum lines over and over
and over with hopefully breaks where
you've got a shark on and then you
actually get to work up that shark
that buoy looks weird the boy looks
weirdo right it's bulbing too yeah it
just went under yeah good signs good
signs
come on shark
there's definitely some resistance yeah
something's on it
really nice shark
the most common species we will get in
Florida is probably going to be a nurse
shark
and disappointingly a nurse shark is
exactly what they have on the line
there's little scientific data the team
can get from one of the most familiar
sharks in the area
you'll feel that man's disappointment
because that's not what we're after and
they're difficult to deal with
all right let's go to the next to the
next one you all set ready yeah all
right hang on
foreign
[Music]
checks the lines for over eight hours
but has little luck does it feel heavy
kind of it's in a shock yeah
all right good job
we spent one day at Bahia Honda bridge
and all we've got to show for it is
Sunburn and two nurse sharks
it's a rare what can you say
we're gonna call it quits and tomorrow
we're going to try out some spots that
were recommended to us we've really only
got one fishing day before the bad
weather sets in and we're benched so
hopefully these spots pan out
the next morning the team is back at it
again and it's not long before they
start seeing sharks okay ready ready yep
this sport was recommended To Us by a
colleague who does a lot of fishing for
sharks and Rays down here and he's
caught plenty of hammerheads they're
coming up
feeling optimistic
primer yeah pull that weight up oh
there's a shock all right oh that's a
blankets
so we want to get a tower rope ready the
really great thing about shark fishing
is that even if we're targeting one
species and we catch another we can
still utilize data from that animal it's
a female got it
and we take genetic samples got it just
a small little fin clip can tell us tons
and tons of information and I'll unlock
huge avenues for us to study
when we catch a shark we're like a pit
crew we have to be quick so everyone has
their job and we try to do things as
quickly as possible to avoid getting
bitten and to keep the shark relaxed the
team flips it upside down putting it
into a hypnotized State called tonic
immobility what is important to realize
is that sharks are all muscle so even a
small shock can cause considerable
damage if someone wants to get bitten
all right who's ready I'm ready okay BCL
95 Fork 109. somebody threw the PEX okay
you want me to do the tail fish yeah
sure
you guys want a d hook okay okay all
right turn one two three
okay all right good work team
there's actually few species of sharks
that I would consider true apex
predators meaning they're at the top of
the food chain gray Hammerheads may be
one of the exceptions especially those
bigger dogs and these are also Shark
Killers gray Hammerheads like to eat
other sharks so sharks will often
feature in their diet
black tips are absolutely potential pre
for these gray Hammerheads so the fact
they're around suggests Predator may be
as well
every winter great Hammerheads await one
of their biggest hunts of the year
tens of thousands of black tip sharks
migrate up the coast of Florida in
search of warmer Waters
only the safety of numbers and shallow
Waters can help them evade this apex
predator
[Music]
we got two more guys two more chances we
just need one oh
choose vertical
you guys got it yeah yeah he's got it
okay man
but it's good it's coming up
it's coming to the surface fast so we
might be good
I see a shadow I don't see the shark yet
it's big holy it's big oh that's a good
one monster whoa
whoa It's a monster whoa
holy cow oh that's a big one no no tiger
tiger sharks tiger
good for your feet
sharks are just one big muscle they are
so much more powerful than us
just have to spin up put it towards you
when you're controlling all the weight
of that shark it's putting its full
force against you it takes almost
everything you have in you to fight that
animal you really have to be physically
ready to take on that battle you know in
reality you should probably lose because
you're sometimes fighting over a
thousand pounds of weight
foreign
although it looks dramatic we keep it to
a minimum with these large animals you
could get a really bad bite obviously
nobody wants to get bitten so our two
priorities are our safety and the shark
safety so we have to work really quickly
to get it processed and released as soon
as possible
really Robin and there's really very
little we can do to fight that strength
so we really have to kind of use
strategy as well to get these animals
under control if we try to go strength
against strength we're going to lose
she's really um
got it yep
careful
got it
completed okay she's gonna chill she's
gonna chill just trying to get her calm
down we've got this shark up to the
surface she had a lot of energy still so
she got pretty active so it's been a
little tricky controlling over now we
have it on her back which will kind of
put in a trance-like state so if you're
going to Tonic immobility it only takes
a few minutes and then she'll start
coming down
eventually
I think she's calming a bit yeah she's
feeling looser on my end
you're gonna give me the DNA tool
it's not every day that you get to work
up but 11 or 12 foot tiger shark
yep all right we got a DNA sample and
even though we were looking for
Hammerheads we collected genetic samples
and took measurements and all of that
goes to our understanding of tiger
sharks and other species of sharks as
well Tiffany we can relate to death
oh good
she's swimming the other way all right
you ready she's coming here she comes
so weather's getting pretty nasty so I
think we should get out of here yeah I
don't see getting a camera tag I think
we just caught it for today yeah let's
call it no no we still got one more
glass coming up looks like there's
something there but who's moving all
over the place
that Bowie's really upright This Could
Be the One
did you see full body out no I just saw
a splash okay
oh it's for real that could be a big
Hammerhead oh yeah
oh
Hello Dolly it's she's swimming she's
swimming she's swimming
there we go three three you good
is it still on I don't think there's
anything on here oh no really yeah that
timer's not hot popped it says five
minutes no no more tension I think it's
off it's gone oh yeah no bait and no
hook no hook
that was a big straight hoe straight and
snap look at that oh wow look at it
that's some serious pressure man I
haven't seen that but we're bringing the
line we clearly had a shark on the end
of the line the line was going up to the
surface which often what Hammerheads do
when they get hooked up so I gotta say I
was pretty hopeful that time but
unfortunately whatever was on there
snapped and straightened the hook
there's probably something really big on
the end of that that was a hammerhead
dang that probably was the biggest
hammerhead in the world well that was a
beast oh that was the one
those are some decent sized stainless
steel hook so it takes a pretty big
animal to be able to straighten it out
and to snap it
was the last one last shot we had it
until we didn't we're gonna have to keep
this even if we don't find the yeah yeah
yeah right
so at the end of the day we didn't catch
the hammerheads that we were looking for
but honestly that's the way that field
work goes these are not animals that are
hugely abundant yeah so it's always a
numbers game whether or not you're going
to catch one I mean no doubt this is a
Sharky place it's just if they're not
gonna beat the Tigers and the nurses to
the punch and take the beat we're not
going to get them yeah it's going to be
a question of effort and luck well we
put in the effort today we just didn't
have any of the left yeah
while the team the team came up empty
can
you hand largest great hamburger
Hammer hint over to judge we actually
got some interesting Intel from the
Bimini shark lab the place where I
started my career two decades ago they
actually saw the biggest hammerhead
they've ever seen at their dive site
last year so it seems like a good spot
to check out
the reason that we don't know a lot
about great hammer heads is because
they're hard to study so the only way
they're going to get this data is just
by continuing to go out and be in the
field as much as possible and eventually
we will get there one thing we do know
about Hammerheads movements is that they
go back and forth between Florida and
the Bahamas and some of them definitely
are coming from this region so that
could be why we're not seeing too many
here in Florida because some of them
have gone to the Bahamas and that's
where we're headed next
foreign
so it was about this time last year that
the shark lab encountered the largest
great Hammerhead that they have on
record which is saying something because
they've seen some pretty big animals any
great Hammerhead sighting would be
spectacular but it would be great to be
able to see her for ourselves
I'm from the Bahamas and any opportunity
to do work in your home country is
something to be really excited about
the entirety of our Waters our stroke
Sanctuary so sharks are very very safe
in our Waters
the Bahamas is one of the best places in
the world for sharks and also
specifically for hammerhead sharks
the team is meeting up with the head of
the Bimini shark lab to learn more about
their sighting of a giant we're kind of
early in the season right now it's just
starting to kick off so we've been out
for the past few weeks actually looking
who's around the shark lab has been here
for 30 years been the lifespan of the
shark lab the hammerheads are relatively
new study but even saying that they've
now been studied by the shark lab for
over a decade so close to 12 years we've
been actually identifying individuals
here
I heard that you guys saw a really big
Hammerhead last year the biggest one
you've ever seen
yeah we're out doing one of our just
normal Dives we had I don't know five or
six different hammerheads and all of a
sudden we just see this massive one kind
of come through the pack and she just
came right through the middle and made
all of the other Hammerheads our normal
ones look relatively average we have
some photos of Queen who is the new
biggest one next to Gaia and she
actually kind of makes guy look like an
average shark which is once you see guy
in the water that's pretty impressive
that she can make her look that small
that's amazing that's crazy so a great
great Hammerhead and we're only looking
at probably the subset that are actually
at the dive site so we think that
there's other residentials that are just
around the island doing normal hunting
Behavior chasing stingrays Eagle Rays
whatever it is and the photo ID is
really only the ones that come to that
provisioning dive site here in Bimini so
it seems like you have almost sort of
two groups of sharks we have some that
are going to be residential and hanging
around the feeding site and others that
are ranging more widely around the
island so maybe we should split into
groups and half of us will go to the
feeding site and then the other group
can go and sort of drive around and see
if we can get some of those more wider
ranging individuals so you all go there
how about we go to Turtle rocks this is
where I saw the biggest hammerhead I've
ever seen in birming two decades ago and
we can work our way along those islands
and check out the flats and stuff places
where there's a lot of food for them
yeah sounds like a really good plan
sounds good that's good
foreign
our planets are split into two groups
myself and Aaron are going to go to the
dive site and dive there which is where
they regularly see the gray hammerheads
and our hope is that we see one of the
largest species and perhaps see Queen
Candace and Damien on the other hand are
going to go to some of the sites where
we know some of the Hammerhead prey
items are found Stingrays and Eagle Rays
so it's always good if you want to see a
big Predator go and hang out in the area
where you know their prey can be found
[Music]
okay well this is the spot where 20
years ago I saw the biggest hammerhead
I've ever seen was right there we were
driving the boat past and we saw this
eagle ray jumping up out of the water
normally they're quite graceful but this
one was distressed it was jumping and
sort of a weird way and then all of a
sudden there was this big explosion of
water and I saw the tail of a shark come
out and so of course I was 22 years old
I got the mask and snorkel and jumped in
to see what was going on I see the eager
a on the bottom disabled it's got a big
bite out of its wing and all of a sudden
you hear everybody starts screaming on
the boat last thing you want to hear
because I don't know about Hammerheads I
don't know how aggressive they are
what's the deal so I looked down and
this gargantuan Hammerhead is coming up
from the bottom and you know their heads
are just getting wider whiter whiter and
I'm like backing up but the thing turns
and I see her eye just sweep over me
take a look and she clearly didn't think
I was a threat didn't think I was a
competitor and then she went back and
she just ate the eagle ray right in
front of me
it was an incredible thing for anybody
to see so with any luck we'll see a big
Hammerhead around here if we're
extremely lucky we could hit the jackpot
twice in 20 years and see a predation
event like that that'll be really cool
yeah let's go check it out let's do it
thank you
while Candace and Damien snorkel the
potential hunting ground in search of a
giant
Giannis and Aaron have been waiting
without much luck well the nurse sharks
are here we've been sitting here at this
spot for a couple hours now and the only
sharks that we've seen are nurse sharks
which are great but that's not what
we're looking for
right now the water's unusually warm and
sharks are sensitive to water
temperatures so they may just not like
these warm Waters even though we know
there's plenty of hammerhead sharks in
the area getting them to the boat is
still a little bit tricky so we're going
to go and do a dive anyway just test out
the gear the lasers the camera with some
nurse sharks which are always in the
area Matt is going to go down start
bedding in these sharks and then fingers
crossed the hammerheads all turn up
[Music]
thank you
everybody's really great
Johnny's gonna have a camera so we can
do some photo ID and then I'm gonna use
some lasers to actually measure how
large some of these animals are
helping out
take a look
a little male
after a really slow start we finally had
some really great action
Matt is baiting you've got a lot of
experience bedding in these sharks
Aaron's going to use the laser
photogrammetry to try and get some size
estimates I'm going to be just taking
pictures because the shark lab keeps the
photo ID they can identify individuals
just from that photograph
y
the tricky part about laser
photogrammetry is they have to swim by
you just right so that those lasers hit
perpendicular to the shark and sometimes
that means it takes a couple tries as
they swim by
[Laughter]
the Hammerhead is a resident male named
Atlas measuring 11 feet long no giant
but a good sign more could be around
wrap
s
on the side
as the Hammerhead leaves a new shark
arrives a tiger shark
but just as quickly as the tiger shark
appears something has scared it off into
the distance
while the dive team waits in hopes of a
giant
Dr Damian Chapman and Candace Fields
continue their search in the wild
hunting grounds and have discovered a
hammerhead Buffet
there's a spot I want to check out that
I've never been to it's called honeymoon
Harbor I've heard there's a big
concentration of stingrays there I've
also heard gray Hammerheads have been
seen dashing in there and chasing the
Stingrays
this is crazy I've always wanted to see
this say they didn't have this when I
was a staff member at the shark lab
years and years ago oh he just nipped me
so what's so great about the Bahamas is
not only that it's a shark Sanctuary but
they also have an abundance of of
reliable food I mean just look at where
we are if you want to find a predator
the best way to do it is to find its
prey
great Hammerheads hunt things like
stingrays I've heard of them taking out
dolphins and they also eat other sharks
so that really puts them at the very top
of the food web
crazy there's so many Southern stingrays
these are really closely related to
sharks some people call them flat sharks
they're in the same group they're all
elasma banks and they have lots of
similar characteristics we've got one
right here
that has no tail and a bite in it I mean
it's not a big shark bite but it's
definitely some damage
you don't have to actually spot the
shark to know that it's around so that's
pretty good evidence that the sharks
around here are definitely preying on
stingrays so this is super cool
sometimes when you see these Hammerheads
even though they're these huge Predators
you see actually lots of marks which are
seemingly markings from stingrays so
it's clearly quite a bottle that goes
down and it's not just a full-blown
Hammerhead takes the win definitely I
mean I think the record is something
like 55 spines in the mouth or the
Hammerhead from eating all these
stingrays in there I've heard of
hammerhead it was still alive and I had
a stingray spine and it's hot which is
just crazy wow it's definitely a
difficult meal it's not something that's
easy to get
having seen predation by a gray
Hammerhead I can tell you firsthand they
are very very capable hunters and they
are always on like other sharks a lot of
times they're not in hunting mode
Hammerheads always seem to be on Hunting
mode I feel like I'm going to be praying
because he's a pretty hungry flat sharks
let's go check out some other spots
around the island and see what we see
sounds good
with evidence of a recent attempted
predation Candace and Damien head to a
new location with a change of tactics
but back at the dive site something has
scared an adult tiger shark away
we have no shocks
all we can do is wait
after all of that waiting everything
kind of happened all at once first we
see a male that we identified as Atlas
and we saw a tiger shark
[Music]
s
heaven
is way bigger
measurement uh he came to the last
second I have to get another pass
Aaron finally manages to get a
measurement of 13.1 feet
it's a shark named Gaia just 18 inches
shy of the official world record it
might not have been the world's largest
hammerhead but she was certainly large
and definitely larger than what we've
seen in our study off of South Florida
millimeter
seeing Gaia and actually having her come
so close that occasionally I had to duck
a little bit is just an incredible
experience
as a shark biologist it always gives me
hope to see animals this large because
obviously a sign of a healthy system is
not just that you see sharks but you're
seeing larger sharks if you're only
seeing smaller animals that's a warning
sign so seeing these truly large near
maximum size sharks is a great sign
[Music]
waiting for hours and hours not sure if
we're gonna get anything and then to
have those two hammers in just within 20
minutes I mean it made it all worth it
yeah it was spectacular it's worth the
wait
on the other side of the island Candace
and Damien are changing tactics and
going with a more high-tech approach hey
Candace is that thing ready yep just
about
well I'm old school used to snorkeling
around and Diving and looking for sharks
but Candace is a great drone pilot
we're right behind the shark lab there's
plenty of stingrays a lot of Life out
here so I could well think we could see
a big Hammerhead out here okay so what
do you think we can do with a drone
survey I think we can do like a transect
around here do you mind
all right doing drone surveys gives us a
whole another dimension to our research
when you're underwater you can only get
so much visibility in front of you above
you below you but when you get that
aerial view you can see so much of
what's going on
really clear yeah that's beautiful white
sand makes it so easy to see stuff we're
lucky here in the Bahamas the water is
so nice and Crystal Clear you can see
everything perfectly especially when you
get a nice calm day and the water is
just glass it almost looks surreal that
you're seeing this clear picture of
these animals from a camera even this
height you can tell someone's swimming
you're pretty good at this yeah yeah I
think you know what you're looking for
well often you use a drone to do things
like a transect survey and you basically
just set two points point a and point B
and you run your drone between them and
you can look at how animals are
responding to the Drone and you can get
a rough estimate on size of animals you
need pretty great conditions so that you
can see clearly the depth has to be just
about right so that you're not getting
refraction of the light and so it can be
challenging at times to use the Drone
but it's something that I think is going
to be a huge tool in science in years to
come
I think I see a turtle now let's check
that out do you think that Turtle no I
think it knows because it's set up when
I lowered it it's better
you can understand how many species are
in an area whether that's all sharks
whether that's sharks and their prey all
right so I think right there is a
stingray probably a southern okay yeah I
see what you're saying yeah okay that's
cool oh I think I see a shark here oh
serious no yeah I think a lemon shark
they definitely hunt the Stingrays just
like the hammerheads do
so that's a good sign that could be
Hammerheads about yeah that lemon shark
is just sort of hanging out in that
seagrass patch yeah I'm sure it's
probably trying to flush some prey or
something yeah
looking at what type of habitat these
guys are using whether they're in the
flats are they going into deeper water
I'm not seeing any hammers over here so
I'm gonna try to head over to some
deeper water and maybe a little bit of
luck we'll see what I'm playing
what's that
that's definitely a hammer oh man that's
a great hammer here that's so cool we
got it now we're cooking this is what we
want this is what we came for
[Music]
we got it we got it it's not a real big
one nicely done so we did see a
hammerhead on the Drone but
unfortunately because of the depth of
the water where we saw it we couldn't
get an exact size yeah it doesn't look
like it's a very big one but it's
undoubtedly a great hammerhead
even though we couldn't get a
measurement it's still super exciting to
just be able to find what we're looking
for these guys are not the easiest to
come by even when you're in Bimini
sometimes you have a tough go at it so
it's really exciting to just even find
one and for me it's super exciting
because it's the first time I've seen
one in its natural habitat
for sure that's really cool all right so
the battery is getting low so I'm going
to bring her back in coming home
[Music]
just because we didn't see the world's
largest hammerhead doesn't mean that
this expedition was a failure
we still got a lot of other really
valuable data from different species
we're really on at the beginning or
early stages of this project so we know
that's going to take time this is going
to be a multi-year project
it was tremendous to go see such a
healthy population and big big animals
honestly I work on these
piece every single time
one face to face it just reminds me why
we need to continue studying this
critically endangered species
[Music]